[Music]
welcome to Episode seven of our series
on Assyrian DevOps I'm Liz Fong Jones a
site reliability engineer at Google
where I teach Google cloud customers how
to build and operate reliable services
[Music]
terribly I was up all night dealing with
these alerts from these systems no it's
just a really hectic night
that's the worst when that happens and
what experience worried users having
were they happier were they impacted by
the alerts mmm
obviously that was the most frustrating
part I get paged about this single
server that had slow or low disk space
or low network bandwidth but only a
small percentage of queries were
affected and by the time I got there the
load balancer already routed traffic
away so there was nothing for me to do
sounds like you have too many alerts and
they're not doing you any good at
actually catching problems affecting
real users and that leaves you really
really tired when something does
actually break so let's see how we can
maybe reduce some of that noise so my
partner and I would greatly appreciate
getting to sleep through the night
unless things are you know actually on
fire but I'm worried too because I've
heard rumors that the rest of my team is
actually ignoring alerts and putting
their phones and do not disturb mode
because none of the alerts are
actionable or very few of them are
actionable and I'm worried that that's
gonna put our business at risk in the
event of a real outage yes so you have
service level indicators and service
level objectives remember last time yeah
we do we have an automated system that
verifies that you can log in you can add
things to your shopping cart and you can
check out and our service level
indicator is defined based on whether
that probe that process succeeds without
error and whether it completes quickly
enough in our timeframe and then our
service level objective or SLO is that
integrated over say the past 30 days and
the SLI must be satisfied for 99.9% or
three nines of all of the probes great
so you're measuring your performance and
what users are experiencing but are you
using that to alert wait you want me to
add more alerts I thought I want to
sleep more
well yes but we'll eventually wind up
turning off the redundant alerts that
are measuring potential causes of
problems rather than corresponding
necessarily to actual and
the users so remember what we're trying
to do is make our users happy so by
using the SLO measurements to decide
whether our users are experiencing
actual symptoms of pain then we can use
that to guide us and everything else is
extraneous okay that makes sense so
let's take an example you said you
wanted to have your sy satisfied 99.9%
over 30 days so that means that you have
an error budget of 43 minutes per 30
days of a hundred-percent outage or
potentially longer if you had a partial
brought out right right that math sounds
familiar
okay so you'd want to find out and be
able to intervene to put the system back
to correctness relatively quickly if you
were expending error budget far more
quickly than the error budget indicates
for instance you clearly have a problem
if you spend a quarter of your error
budget for the whole month within two
hours either by being hard down for 10
minutes or by having a partial Brown out
of ten percent of your probes for those
two hours well I see and if that pattern
continued for the next few hours or even
minutes I could potentially wind up
spending my entire error budget for the
quarter or the year exactly but we can't
put it on a hair-trigger or else it will
falsely alert us when we have a blip for
two minutes
rather than something that winds up
repeating itself within the next two
hours so we can have some situations
where a partial brownout wouldn't
necessarily endanger our error budget
yeah I mean I've had enough noisy pages
to want to avoid that happening ever
again but I think I can spot a small
hole in your logic like what if I
deployed some code that introduced say a
small performance regressions something
maybe half of a percent of mic probes
will constantly fail I'd never catch it
by looking for too many failures in a
window of hours that would be
indistinguishable from other noise in
the system yes you're exactly correct so
we also need a slow burn alert to track
down over the past week if we're
exceeding our error budget at an
acceptable rate for instance we could
check whether more than 0.15 percent of
queries were failing when were only
allowed point one percent and we could
raise a lower priority ticket that
someone could look at during business
hours once we are sufficiently confident
so as I understand it we need both fast
burn and slow burn alerts to provide a
feedback loop on our SLO and make sure
that we're fixing real issues that are
affecting real users exactly and staff
our SLO from Google cloud can help you
by automatically determining and showing
to you what your error budget is how
much of
spend and alerting you when it's in
danger and once you've set up these SLO
based alerts you can turn off all of the
noisy alerts because you're only getting
alerts about the high importance
problems that are actually causing user
impact okay but how do I actually find
the problems in my system so that I feel
confident
turning off the no longer needed alerts
I'm I'm worried that I'm gonna lose data
or be unable to fix issues now that
sounds like an excellent subject for us
to discuss on the next episode about
observability of distributed systems
thanks to everyone for watching and
we'll catch you next time please
remember to Like and subscribe below
[Music]